what's happening reject nation thanks so
much for clicking on this video we're
gonna watch today the cowboy bebop
trailer but before i go change my shirt
and my overall appearance we got a shout
out today's video sponsor which is
skillshare cool what's skillshare
are you joking
no no not at all should i be uh
no skillshare is the most prolific
learning community on the internet they
have literally thousands of classes
dedicated to helping you grow your
existing skills and unlocking new ones
like john w what's up what's a passion
for you
money
we go out that's great because i'd
actually just checked out emily simcox's
bookkeeping for freelancers course oh
wow does she discuss the different kinds
of bookkeeping and ways to strategize
your finances come tax
time yeah
that's exactly what she did she's even
got tips for organizing your documents
and decided what kind of official
business organization is best for you
dude that sounds amazing where can i
take this course on skillshare why are
you
what is skillshare
the first thousand people to use our
link can get a free trial it's a
skillshare premium membership oh
skillshare
i i know what skillshare is i've written
a few ads for skillshare actually
[Music]
so what brings you back from the dead
oh we can go i did a job
about me
believe it or not
he know what you used to be
[Music]
will i ever see you again
[Music]
the actress went down yeah
i go by spike's people these days
looks good
visuals are good
[Applause]
in the solar system
[Music]
what happened
that was dreamy
fellas
thinking
going my way of course
oh
[Music]
and three of us
go grab some bounties
please i just want to kill it a little
bit
oh we got a water up in here
[Music]
i was vicious back there
[Music]
bathroom fight
or bad guys
depends on who you ask
[Music]
do i need to watch this trailer again
perhaps let's go for two on that
copyright yeah
we're going to be getting ready
oh yeah no no i think i know how i feel
about this visually they've managed to
bring sub of like
for a reference but like a panel of the
life like the aesthetic the color
palette and such and the costume design
and the sets the beatbox a big part of
this show is the the chemistry amongst
our three main characters
you know
scooby shag and velvet
[Laughter]
and spike there's still no ed in here
huh one of them has added they just
haven't revealed that but you got is
there a reason there's no end but there
you go we got i need here they're making
it a surprise because i looked this up
because i've seen the comments of people
being like where's ed since the teaser
and they've just said that you're gonna
be really delighted by ed yes whenever
ed shows up what this trailer seems like
it's doing to be a tad bit more
optimistic or editing the trailers i saw
the other one they did too
to the the spirit of what the opening
theme song provides but the the show to
me and you get a kind of a sense of it
in the opening scene here with anna film
noir
sci-fi
western and right now it's kind of doing
for me is capturing the madcap zaniness
of that opening theme song
and splicing the trailer together
for that and yes it is just a trailer
and honestly i don't feel like netflix
makes the greatest trailers probably
copyright claims all the time let other
people get away with it
but i don't feel like they make like the
greatest edited trailers for the most
part oftentimes i watch their shows and
i'm like man this show is so much better
than the trailer i want to be optimistic
for it just because of all the the you
know the baggage that adapting anime
often brings to it so while there's like
elements here that are bringing its
likeness to to the forefront i really
don't know how i feel i'm like this is
kind of working on a nostalgic element
sure i want to revisit cowboy b-pop
which is going to be great that's just
that's how you should do it
revisit the crew of the great show right
before watching the adaptation just so i
do nothing but compared to the show yeah
yes but i do want to revisit it
obviously this is the the marketing at
least is placating and pandering
specifically towards the people who are
fans of cowboy people because i feel
like if you don't watch cowboy bebop
you're kind of like i don't know what's
happening but this looks cool you know
yeah it's got a lot of crazy sets and
production values and whatnot but yeah
yeah i feel like it's always hard to
encapsulate a show in a trailer anyway
and i mean to me i haven't seen the
entire show i've been working my way
through the show and one thing that's
very much endeared me you have this
oscillating tone where you have yeah the
sci-fi and the madcap and the fun and
the action but it's also intermixed with
all the requisite action and plot stuff
that you want all the sci-fi goodies but
also then really seamlessly and
conscientiously they weave that in with
these very like when the show hits
transcendence it goes into these places
where it's you know very textural and
tonal and it's just the music coalescing
with the visuals and whatnot and then a
lot of the time you're kind of just like
in the day-to-day of these situations
with them and there's a lot of esoterica
that's a bit quieter than this yeah
that's what i mean yeah so i feel like
this trailer isn't necessarily going for
that and it's hard to bring that to a
trailer the trailers are mainly
capitalizing on like the pulpy
uh you know madcap qualities but i i
don't really
think of that when i flashed a cowboy
beep off because it's a slower paced
show that people realize if you haven't
seen it it's that this actually strikes
more of a western film noir tone like
tonally atmospheric and not that this
needs to be a one-to-one direct
adaptation but this really seems to be
like amplifying up the wackiness and
comedy of it when really there's a lot
of dramatic heft that i i feel like they
should definitely bring to life here
that i'm not really getting a sense of
like look i'll be honest the show this
looks cool to me yeah this looks really
cool if i if i remove myself entirely
from any preconceived notions bringing
from the anime i would watch this and go
this looks really cool this looks really
wild this looks really entertaining
creative
and so yeah i mean if if i completely
separate myself a thousand percent this
looks like a lot of fun but at the same
time though i'm not really getting a
sense of if i completely remove myself
from the show i'm like i kind of got a
sense of the characters here i i'm
liking what john cho is going for would
capture the apathetic nature of um spike
essentially is what he's trying to do
right yeah that very relaxed too cool
yeah yeah but i see a lot of people
might come here but all you're doing is
compared to the show i'm like well the
shows and the marketing's just trying to
make it zoning in on your love for the
show well you're gonna compare it when
that's what the marketing is doing one
big part of what they're trying to do is
realize the show i don't think they're
making an effort to go way off the
beaten path of what the show is i feel
like part of the point is that they do
want to translate it as faithfully and
within the spirit as they've said often
as they want to do it in the spirit when
they say that i don't see anything that
fully encapsulates the spirit yeah not
not from this trailer and two i mean one
benefit of the doubt i'll give them is i
think for characters like this
especially in live action and in things
that are more stylized and zany things
that need time for you to kind of
breathe with them and see how they
operate in actual scenes as actual
people on screen i feel like it's hard
to encapsulate characters like this in a
way that plays
great across the trailer that's why i
think our talk which a lot of people
will completely overlook is we're
talking about the marketing specifically
yeah and what they're presenting to us
yeah and i feel like every time they
present something to us it's just the
spirit of the opening credits
yes that's pretty that's pretty much all
i've gotten thus far from the ads yeah
and some of the more bleak darker
visuals look more
the spirit and less sin city is how i
put it yeah yeah
yeah i know what you mean by yeah
yeah and i'm worried as to which one
this is gonna be because it could easily
be one or the other it's a wacky
cartoony adaptation and what i'm like
when you're watching anime it's easy to
take that [ __ ] seriously because when
you see the rose drop into the puddle
there i'm like cartoony yeah and that's
the trouble is if that stuff isn't taken
with as much credence and and isn't
given as much seriousness as all the mad
cap is it's gonna feel silly yeah right
now i'm on definitely like
treading water here i'm cautious
optimistic that's where i have landed i
want it to work i i i know that if i've
never seen cow any of cowboy bebop i
would have been right here being like
looks like a lot of fun and inventive
i'm all for going into a show and going
what are they doing with their
characters and then completely removing
myself from what the show what the ip
has done before i just
and i can easily accept like okay here
are the new things that they're doing
and i could totally get on board for
that i do wonder though if if if i will
that's the main question yeah that's the
main spirit you gotta capture do they
understand the spirit is the question
they're at odds because they're trying
to capture the spirit but they also want
to do their own thing and sometimes that
can be very conflicting
yeah and so yeah it's good to be it's
good to be a little uh a little worried
leave your thoughts down below did the
trailer do it for you are you filled
with chills what are your feelings but
hey before we end this let's shout out
some patrons and thank you skillshare
for sponsoring this video long schlong
aerocons 39 on my dime kusi kusi i hope
i don't know i'm gonna have to figure
out how to say your name for reals matt
nathan damon's no one's ever said that d
welch is 18 and the 18 looks like two
grapes welch's quantity tuggle snuggle
boggle william lane bryant
who
lane bryant is a bra company kill phil
eider
chris in lawson there's a care bear in
the garage rosa bruce lee taylor nick x
gonna give it to you what gail from sin
city ferguson jaren wan
her
stacks da crook
sniff cliff rodriguez chris evans is
busting
mr crispy lippy danny pancakes the man
cakes alex beau weber kathleen kennedy
everyone's favorite producer mar olivia
delgade with the spy and all the lies as
she cries into the
apple pies differently saying in the
membrane
i'm jazzed about kaz pattern awesome hey
thank you guys so much for showing your
support over at our patreon page
hopefully it's not too difficult to
navigate
this tier but seriously your support is
uh overwhelming
thank you so much and uh
don't that
was overwhelming that's some improv
right there hey
[Music]